Hello world it Saroj and
how am I so productive?
I get that question a lot.
So in this video I'm going to reveal
five ways that I personally maintain my
productivity. If you're new here,
hit subscribe to get notified.
When I released my weekly
educational videos every week,
I make three or four technical videos
that teach complex topics in technology
like artificial intelligence,
blockchain,
and quantum computing in the most simple,
understandable way that I can.
On top of that,
I run an international nonprofit called
school of Ai that consists of 800
representatives called beans across
400 cities globally and it's growing
insanely fast.
It's a lot of work.
The list of tasks is endless from
web development to partnerships,
legalities, coordination,
creating guidelines, et cetera.
It's very stressful,
but totally and completely worth it.
There's literally nothing I'd rather do
with my time than what I'm doing right
now.
That being said,
the first way I stay productive is
that I protect my mental health.
In the past few months,
lots of popular youtube ers from h three
h three to Fusi tube to the try guys
have come forward to talk
about how they've had mental
breakdowns for making so
many videos.
The coupling of constant changes to
YouTube's algorithm with the unhealthy
obsession with remaining relevant to
keep audience metrics up has caused the
burnouts amongst youtubes,
most popular creators.
I've been doing this for two and a half
years now and there's definitely been
moments where I've felt
extremely stressed,
but in order for me to be able to
continue our mission of providing a world
class AI education to as
many people as possible,
I realize that my mental health
should be my number one priority.
I can't deliver content constantly to
you wizards unless I'm mentally stable,
so I consciously make time to disconnect.
Every week I spend one day,
one full 24 hour period without my phone.
I am completely disconnected from
the Internet. Also every night,
the three hours before I sleep,
I disconnect as well.
I spend that time either by myself or
with friends just playing for the sake of
playing.
My full time role as director of school
of Ai is to inspire and educate and
social media is the platform with
which I've been doing that so far.
It's how I've been able to reach
so many people across the world,
so it's absolutely crucial to what I do,
but simultaneously social media
is harmful to mental health.
Jerome Linear,
the author of 10 arguments for deleting
your social media right now has this to
say about social media usage because
you're being certainly manipulated
by algorithms that are watching everything
you do constantly and then sending
you changes in your media feed and your
diet that are calculated to adjust you
slightly to the liking of
some unseen advertiser.
The irony here is that Jerome was one
of the pioneers of the worldwide web and
advocated for a world of free
services that anybody could use,
but drone has seen the harmful effects
of what social media has become.
I don't want to let social media
manipulate me. I want to manipulate it.
I want to be the one in control,
not the algorithms.
So not only do I limit the
time that I am on social media,
when I do use it,
I use it specifically to either engage
with the community or share content,
meaning I literally scheduled time to
answer questions and reply to messages for
each of the respective social media
platforms that I use and I schedule when I
share my videos as well.
Another part of protecting my mental
health is by relying on a supportive
community.
This community,
the school of Ai shares
seven values and a mission.
And because we share these values,
it makes it easier for us to build
lasting relationships with each other.
Vulnerability is the foundation by
which close friendships are made.
So I've made a point to be as vulnerable
as I can with all of you sharing my
deepest secrets publicly rather
than keeping them bottled up inside,
like the fact that I've legally changed
my name twice or the fact that I was
fired from my last job and because of it,
I've observed that I've been able
to reach a new level of intimacy and
connection with this community.
We really are one big family and I hope
to see each of you be more vulnerable
with each other as well.
Negative emotions are okay to feel.
It's a really important lesson
that I learned from the book,
the subtle art of not giving an f.
It's okay to feel
anxious or sad or guilty,
but social media and its current state
makes us believe for a large part that if
we're not being positive,
something's wrong with us and that can
lead to a thoughts spiral where we feel
anxious about being anxious and sad
about feeling sad or worrying about
worrying,
accepting that negative emotions
are an inevitable part of life.
That there will always be some problem
that I'll have has freed me to have
better mental health.
The second way that I stay
productive is that I say no.
I am constantly saying no every single
day I'm saying no to potential business
clients, relationships, video suggestions,
advice on which direction to take school
of Ai and I'm saying no to myself as
well.
I have so many things that I want to do,
so many different and ideas,
but I know that as a human being with
the limited time on earth and a limited
span of attention,
I can't do it all.
If I try to do too many things at once,
then each of those things won't
be as quality as they could be.
One of my first inspirations to adopt
this type of mentality was the way Steve
jobs handled his return to apple years
later after being fired previously
and focusing is hard because
focusing doesn't mean saying yes,
it means saying no.
So we say we,
we decide not to do a lot of things so
that we can focus on a few handfuls of
things and do them well.
Focus means saying no.
Our slack channel has over
25,000 developers on it.
I say no to being very active in all
of the hundred plus channels we have,
but say yes to being very active in the
dean's channel where our deans share
their experiences, building AI
communities in their respective cities.
In fact, I like and comment on
every single post in that channel.
I am the most active person on it.
Attention is a valuable thing,
including in deep learning and as a human
I can only spread my attention so much
so I actively choose to
target that attention to areas
where it matters the most
to help achieve the goals
I've set for myself.
The third way I stay productive
is by asking for help.
Since I started my youtube channel,
I've always had the goal of solving AI
and using it to solve the world's hardest
problems and starting my youtube
channel alone allowed me to make all the
decisions myself.
I know myself,
I trust myself and because of that I was
able to both make and implement a lot
of decisions very fast,
both in terms of the content of my videos
and the direction I wanted to take the
channel.
I had no boss,
but at some point I realized that in
order to actually accomplish my goal,
I need it to scale and scaling
meant asking other people for help,
leveraging other human brains to
help me accomplish the larger goal.
The first step in that direction was
hiring a full time editor and animator.
I used to edit all my videos
myself and that's how I liked it.
I didn't think any editor would be able
to edit machine learning equations on a
screen the way that I could,
but eventually I found and learn to trust
my now full time editor and animator
and I followed a similar thought pattern
when it came to social media promotion.
The social media work I used to do myself
like Seo and general growth strategies
is now done by my social media manager.
Even content creation.
Our School of AI deans are
creating their own curriculums,
their own educational AI videos
and imbuing it with their own.
It's not just me anymore.
I have learned to ask for help across
my entire work pipeline and I'm still
learning how to ask for help.
I have a giant list of tasks I need to
complete and if it was humanly possible,
I would do it all myself,
but I'm learning how to pick and choose
those tasks that are best suited for me
to do and ask for help from specific
deans at our school for the rest.
This ongoing practice has
definitely boosted my productivity.
The fourth way I stay productive is
by performing rapid experimentation.
This is actually one of
our values at school of Ai.
An idea alone is worth nothing.
It's the execution of it that matters
and the best way to do that is to build,
assess, and reiterate until you
have a valid solution to a problem.
That 100 days of ml code challenge the
Drake in my feelings AI challenge and
even the entire school of AI organization,
all three of these initiatives I started
in the past three months and each was
launched with a single video on youtube.
Each of these initiatives
could have gone horribly wrong.
They could have been received negatively
and misunderstood like Saroj coin was,
but because I have the mentality of
rapid experimentation of just putting
something out there,
seeing what people feel and then
iterating until it's better.
I had the courage to put those ideas out
into the world regardless of how people
felt.
It's okay to fail.
I embrace failure wholeheartedly
and so should you.
It's a part of rapid experimentation.
It means we're learning
and growing as humans.
It also means that I can quickly see
what works and what doesn't work,
which saves me a lot of time and the fifth
way that I stay productive is through
detailed planning.
At the start of every week,
I use a dedicated segment of my time,
usually about five hours,
but it can take up to 10 hours
sometimes. The plan. I plan my week,
month, year, and five years
and as much detail as I can,
listing out my goals for each of these
time intervals and then for my week plan,
how I'm going to achieve those goals.
Specifically,
I try and plan out every single
hour of my day for the entire week,
which includes planning time to rest
and rejuvenate and all of my to do tasks
change every single week.
Nothing is ever static,
but because I take the initiative to plan,
I feel more secure with what I'm doing
and I'm able to effectively prioritize
and organize all of the tasks that
I need to do in an efficient way.
And that's pretty much it. I'm definitely
a human with flaws and I make mistakes,
but I learned from them and I'm committed
to growing both myself as a human and
community for the better.
I live to serve a AI wizards.
It brings me a very deep sense of joy
in a way that nothing else ever has.
So thank you for watching and for
being a part of this community.
What do you do to stay productive?
Share it in the comment section.
I'll pin the reply that
people find most useful.
Please subscribe for
more educational videos.
And for now I've got to say yes to
my wizards, so thanks for watching.